a medida que transcurren las horas vamos
conociendo más detalles de una tragedia
que afecta a seis estados a través de 30
tornados que han ido causando
destrucción a su paso los más severos
aquí en kentucky donde por ejemplo en la
ciudad de mayfield de unos diez mil
habitantes ha visto como gran parte de
su población perdía sus casas reducidas
a escombros esa es una imagen que
impacta muchísimo en el centro de una
ciudad que también ahora mismo está
trabajando en el rescate de personas por
ejemplo en una fábrica de velas que
tiene 100 trabajadores y no se ha podido
identificar las personas que han podido
quedado sepultadas entre los escombros
también en una fábrica de amazon en la
región es un momento complicado lo
reconocía el propio gobernador con
lágrimas en los ojos y es que la lista
de fallecidos va incrementándose pero es
momento de salvar vidas y de dar
soluciones a una población que no había
visto nada similar en su historia